und sie haben ja die reichen müssen
zahlen ist ihre these ich bin sehr
gespannt wie wir das so finden ja also
im grunde kann nicht dort anschließen wo
paul zimmer aufgehört es geht darum wir
leben jetzt gerade die ukraine sind land
das in trümmern liegt man schätzt
ungefähr 750 milliarden euro betragen
die materiellen schäden dieses
menschliche leid kann man sowieso nicht
aufwiegen und die frage stellt sich
nicht nur wer zeit den wiederaufbau der
ukraine wenn es hoffentlich irgendwann
mal was zum aufbauen gibt sondern auch
wer trägt auch die kosten der versorgung
die wir hier haben in europa wir leisten
gerade sehr sehr großes vor allem polen
deutschland österreich und so weiter und
da ist meine these dass diejenigen die
sich in den letzten 20 jahren unter
putins regime wirklich bereichert haben
auch am russischen volk aber auch an der
welt nämlich die oligarchen die vor
allem in deutschland in österreich in
frankreich und großbritannien groß für
die sitznummer angehäuft haben die 100
milliarden an besitztümern dort
gebunkert haben auch zur kasse gebeten
werden und gleichzeitig nämlich nicht
nur die russischen oligarchen sondern
auch die deutschen und österreichischen
oligarchen unter anführungszeichen also
diejenigen die jetzt in der krise
profitieren die jetzt in der krise in
den letzten monaten aber auch in den
letzten jahren ihr vermögen massiv
steigern konnten auch die sollten zur
kasse gebeten werden wenn wir sehen dass
jetzt die lebensmittelpreise steigen die
gaspreise steigen und so weiter
ich glaube sie sind spannender punkt den
die da machen und einer über den wir
auch durchaus wirklich intensiv und
ernsthaft diskutieren sollten ich finde
bei dem punkt bemerkenswert wenn wir
einmal anschauen wie viel vermögen denn
eigentlich von oligarchen in den
vergangenen wochen eingefroren ist und
dass so ein bisschen europäisch
beleuchten dann stellen wir in dem fall
auch leider wieder fest dass offenbar
wie in deutschland hier ein bisschen
einmal mehr auf die bremse treten das
sind so rund 100 millionen euro im
volumen was bisher an vermögen
eingefroren wurde wir wissen
beispielsweise aus belgien da ist es
über eine milliarde schon auch in
italien rund eine milliarde an vermögen
von oligarch jetzt kann man sagen
italiens ist die mafia bekämpfung quasi
staatsräson das heißt da ist man viel
besser ausgerüstet das kann sein aber es
zeigt sich einmal mehr ich glaube ich ja
deutschland gewaltigen nachholbedarf was
dieses thema angeht und am ende wenn sie
die kern frage auf wer bezahlt und ich
glaube dass wir das zum einen bei den
oligarchen abladen sollten aber auch
nicht ganz vergessen sollten das auch
der russische staat am ende für den
wiederaufbau mitbezahlen muss also ich
denke wir sollten da ein bisschen
vorsichtig sein einfach zu sagen die
reichen per se sollen jetzt alles für
alles bezahlen und für alles aufkommen
deutschland ist und bleibt ein
rechtsstaat er und enteignungen gibt es
in deutschland nicht ja außer unter ganz
bestimmten voraussetzungen so und jetzt
zu sagen wir nehmen anderen menschen das
vermögen weg und und schichten das quasi
um damit nehmen wir uns eine menge damit
nehmen wir uns eine menge von unseren
prinzipien von unseren rechtsstaatlichen
prinzipien und mir ist es persönlich
wichtig dass das erhalten bleibt wir
konfiszieren das vermögen ja wir nehmen
es praktisch zur seite wir machen es
nicht mehr verfügbar aber jetzt einfach
zu sagen damit lösen wir die krise das
ist eben nicht die lösung und ich habe
in der tat auch sorge dass das wieder
mal eine blaupause für andere dinge sein
kann dass der staat sich willkürlich
dann auch wiederum bei anderen menschen
bedient die hart für ihr geld gearbeitet
haben oder dies geerbt haben hier auch
immer das ist gut dass es richtig das
darf auch sein und deswegen warne ich
vor solchen populistischen vorschlägen
das für die große vielleicht kurzes
sozusagen nur weil das natürlich ist
eine blaupause ist klar natürlich sollen
bin ich bin russischen oligarchen
entscheiden wenn sie ich meine wirklich
jetzt in berlin in berlin gibt es glaube
ich ein recht erfolgreiches
volksbegehren deutsche wohnen der eigner
es geht darum quasi leistbar zu machen
und ich denke mir natürlich müssen wir
und das ist kristallisationspunkt in
dieser krise quasi das wir sehen dass
auf der einen seite multimilliardäre
besitz in schuss bringen während
gleichzeitig menschen hungern und leiden
aber das gleiche thema haben wir in
deutschland ich finde das deswegen so
wie ich die persönliche grundsatzdebatte
führen übrigens nicht abseits des
rechtsstaats weil letztlich ist der
rechtsstaat das was wir als die in der
demokratie in der gemeinheit dann würden
sie enteignen ich finde es obszön dass
es menschen gibt wie zb klaus michael
kühne der in der krise vor seinem
vermögen von 13 milliarden auf 34
milliarden sein persönliches vermögen
steigern können aber jetzt jetzt für das
ist in gewissen dingen ein drauf ist als
ausgleich wird wenn wir bei oligarchen
über unrechtmäßig erworbenen wohlstand
reden dann ist das das eine und wenn wir
über ganz legal erworbenen wohlstand ist
dass das andere was haben sie denn
dagegen wenn jemand hart arbeitet wenn
jemand arbeitsplätze schaffen wenn
jemand verantwortung für hundert
vielleicht tausend vielleicht 20 400.000
mitarbeiter hat und dafür am ende gerade
steht wenn es schiefgeht aber dafür
natürlich auch belohnt wird wenn es gut
läuft wenn er sich einsetzt kann ich
sagen was genau dahinter liegt auf ihnen
zu sagen überhaupt nichts dagegen zu
sagen natürlich wollten wir
sind also ich habe also erst mal ich
finde es seltsam dass die kühne gruppe
kurzarbeit beantragt einen krise aber in
der anderen situation wo die milliarden
profite sprudeln nicht an den staat
zurückzahlen das wenig seltsam ich finde
es seltsam dass arbeitnehmerrechte mit
füßen getreten werden ein europaweiter
betriebsrat immer noch verhindert wird
in diesem unternehmen einen während in
deutschland der betreiber also interesse
habe ja es sind ja jetzt unter jetzt
vermischen sie aber leider ganz kann da
ein bisschen oder gleich erklären nein
gibt sie vermischen dass man kann über
die frage reden wenn jemand staatshilfen
bekommt muss er sie zurückzahlen das hat
ja nichts mit der eignung zu tun das
sind ja völlig unterschiedliche dinge
die selten tief sie habe sich selten
aber wir lassen sie uns einmal in die
vergangenheit gehen ist noch gar nicht
so lange her ich erinnere mich selbst
daran weil ich noch ein junger mensch
war und immer wieder das vergnügen hatte
in die ddr fahren zu dürfen ein land in
dem es in dem es so gut wie kein
privateigentum aber nur staatseigentum
gab und wenn ich das so richtig noch in
erinnerung habe dann hatte ich immer den
eindruck ob ich mir die häuser
angeschaut habe die autos auch beim
thema umwelt das irgendwie die
bundesrepublik als ein system das auch
eigenkapital auch viel zugelassen hat
oder privateigentum irgendwie in vielen
dingen der ddr vorauswahl beim thema
sauberkeit beim thema das können wir die
gleichen jetzt aber klar aber sie können
doch nicht die haftungsübernahme die wir
unter den solidarbeitrag gehen wir von
superreichen verlangen damit vergleichen
mit dem was in der ddr war wie man das
angesprochene die anhand von
verantwortung übernahmen sie einfache
steuerung geworden eines hinten
immobilienkonzern habe ich mir gerade
selbst gesagt habe gesagt dass ich in
berlin dass gerade passiert ist dass
offensichtlich eine mehrheit der
bevölkerung gab also ich weiß nicht ob
die gegen die interessen eigenen
bevölkerung sprechen aber ich sage ihnen
das was hier gerade passiert und das was
mich ärgert ich bin ja hier durch
beliebten zum ersten mal hier und ich
hab mich im vorfeld ein bisschen
informiert die zahlen und statistiken
aus berlin und ich habe festgestellt
dass 27 prozent aller in berlin wie
werden kinder am trend so aufwächst und
gleichzeitig eine legale deutscher
oligarch seinen gewinn innerhalb von
einem jahr und 20 milliarden euro
gesteigert das ist doch krank wenn wir
das ist hier sitzen und sagen wenn wir
jetzt über die besteuerung von
superreichen reden das sind ja gleich im
kommunist einige komponenten
jemand ein milliardenschwerer sie haben
schon ein eignung gesprochen und das
muss man dann grundsätzlich machen den
bezug auf die karten
für die diskussion ist eine blaupause
für die diskussion ab welchen vermögen
greift der staat ein und ich kenne
meinen lage immer noch mehr als eine
milliarde ich bin da ich bin tatsächlich
der meinung diese diskussion haben wir
auch in schweden die haben in österreich
genauso dass jemand der ein
milliardenvermögen hat tauchen ja
mit was macht der mit dem milliarden nur
unsinn leider ist das so wie bisher mit
dem panama papers wieder was die leute
damit machen sie was ob ein milliardär
hopp ein milliardär das geld in seine
firma stecken oder für eine milliarde
champagnerflaschen kauft das ist am ende
wurst wein das ist ja nicht noch
natürlich nachher gibt das geld aus
ergeben denjenigen die in der champagne
firma arbeiten einen sicheren job dass
er uns mit
seinem eingenommen ins labor wie sehen
sie das
[Gelächter]
weil einmal nach ist es absolut nicht ob
superstar glaube ich jetzt gar nicht so
da springe ich glaube wir sind alle
darin einig dass wir uns in deutschland
auch in österreich massiv unterscheiden
möchte und es auch tun von anderen
ländern nicht auf dasselbe rechtsstaat
niveau absenken wie zb die totalitäre
regime da kann man glaube ich allen
punkten machen so dann aber auch die
rolle deutschlands in österreich wenn
wir darüber sprechen wie wir mit solchen
oligarchen umgehen ich denke das geht
nur im internationalen rahmen schweiz
monaco großbritannien ich glaube die
haben deutlich größere probleme ich
glaube mit denen sollte man sprechen
wenn wir sagen wir wollen die tradition
sprechen
die yachten der oligarchen liegen in der
regel nicht in bremerhaven oder in
rostock das eis im internationalen
verbund sich gedanken zu machen wie man
etwas reagieren könnte wäre
wahrscheinlich dass genau das richtige
ganz unabhängig davon müsse natürlich
diejenigen belangt werden die zunahme
kreml sind ich denke auch da sind wir
uns einig dass
dieses vermögen gesperrt werden muss
völlig unabhängig davon was das dann für
konsequenzen hätte wir wollen dieses
system natürlich in keiner art und weise
dar und unterstützt noch eine ergänzung
zur frau bosbach gehe ich mit aber der
reflex der hinter solchen forderungen
steht ist ja immer der zu glauben man
kann damit krisen lösen man bedient sich
einfach bei anderen menschen und kann
damit krisen lösen löcherstopfen
schulden senken was auch immer aber das
ist ja nicht der fall wir haben es
gesehen am ende führen solche
instrumente dann auch zu einem ab
wirtschaften eines staates und zu dem
was ich selbst als kind erlebt habe aber
jetzt mal kurz bleiben wir ein punkt es
geht ihm ums geld okay es geht da wir
dort immer ums geld und zu sagen wir
können keine probleme lösen indem wir
das geld von denen die zu viel davon
haben dorthin geben wo es zu wenige
wieder schneit ist ein guter unternehmer
die frage
haben die aufgabe staat ist nicht
unternehmerisch zu agieren die aufgabe
des staates ist das gemeinwohl zu
fördern und die ausgabe startet muss
sein dafür zu sorgen dass ist
ausbalanciert
wenn wir erleben es noch dazu wenn wir
erleben dass in den krisen ob corona
krise oder ukraine krise manche menschen
immer reicher werden wären ganz viele
menschen sich ihre wohnung nicht mehr
leisten können jetzt nicht mehr leisten
können dann läuft und dann zu sagen es
werden keine probleme mit der
umverteilung von geld gelöst ist einfach
unsinn das stimmt mich natürlich werden
probleme mit umverteilung gelöst aber
das heißt ja nicht dass wir den krieg
auch beenden gesagt ich habe auch nicht
gesagt dass dadurch dass wir die
russischen oligarchen in deutschland in
österreich und so weiter enteignen der
krieg gelöst wird aber eines müssen wir
schon erkennen dass leute wie
abramowitsch jetzt am verhandlungstisch
sitzen als milliardär hat nur einen
einzigen grund weil sie angst um ihr
geld haben und ich glaube dass putin
wird gestützt von einer elite von
menschen den letzten 20 jahre aufgebaut
hat und die haben wahnsinnig viel geld
und sie treffen wir am stärksten wenn
wir das geld nehmen aber es gibt glaube
ich da wirklich unterschiede zwischen
einem ehrbaren kaufmann und jemandem der
seinen milliarden familie avisiert
eingangs auch sagten auf unehrliche art
und weise bekommen hat so und
durchdiener tun das ist ja schon ein
unterschied wie eine herrliche kaufmann
der ist der ehrliche kaufmann der
betriebsrats gründungen in seinem
betrieb verhindert der jenige der auf
kinderarbeit seine produkte stützt das
ist der ehrliche qualität
wir haben wir haben keine augen
geschlossen oder nicht und auch die idee
dahinter ist dass die unternehmen was
man unterschied es zu ihnen ich würde
erstmal sagen ein unternehmer der
anfängt zu arbeiten ist per se erst mal
ein guter mensch das sehen sie
wahrscheinlich anders sie unterstelle
mein unternehmen dahin war ich bin
selber unternehmer ja das ist ja
wunderbar für die daten genau und dann
kann man doch immer darüber reden ob es
dass es unternehmer gibt die
möglicherweise nicht so agieren wie sie
das gut finden oder wir das alle gut
finden das bedeutet aber noch nicht dass
sie per per sie jedem unternehmer sei
auch nie gesagt man weiß nicht was wir
reden also ich rede von milliardären
genau das war in korea ein vermögen auf
den großgeräten
doch das kann man da doch die chancen
aber rächen
sich die liste mit jahre anschauen und
sagen du musst dir vor glatten an woher
kommt denn in dem moment wo wir haben
uns einmal war steffen ein paar
nacheinander wer sich kein süßes
familien da müssen wir schon aus
reformieren ich habe gesagt schauen sie
in groß schauen
sie der familie ist stimmt was steckt
dahinter ja wo kommt das geld her aber
wissen sie ja und jetzt mit einvernahmen
ich bin rausgegangen vorbeigegangen
jetzt schaut bitte auf das ihr zustand
so peinlicher
es geht es geht darum wer hat sein
vermögen auf ausbeutung in deiner ersten
zeit gegründet sie haben aber jetzt okay
doch aufpassen jetzt müssen wir
aufpassen dass wir sagen nein wir sind
was sie vor einige sagen sie wollen eine
grenze bei einer milliarde einführen und
stellt was ich jeden der still war es
unter generalverdacht liebe handelt
nicht ich hab gesagt sie haben mich
befragen wir
besser kennen zu reden wir drüber ja
genau hinter nehmen und mehr als eine
milliarde könne nicht jede über eine
milliarde geeignet oder einen kleinen
sie haben hat sein vermögen mit
verbrechen gemacht war noch ihre worte
natürlich wir sehen ja
ich würde sagen familie haupt von
tengelmann zum beispiel würde ich ganz
klar sagen es definitiv und ehrbare
kaufleute ja ok auch kann ich mir gerne
an schon über die nächsten 10 welche
übrigens noch ein paar andere listen
nach der sendung werden alle
recherchieren sehr gut das ist ein
großes versprechen alle milliardäre
werden recherchiert von herborn